after a year of pretty incessant bad
news we're now starting to get some good
news both about vaccinations but also
about the state of the global economy
the international monetary fund giving
us
its latest update and just have a look
at what it says it's going to happen for
uk economic growth you can see and
you'll probably be familiar with what
happened in 2020 a very big fall
down by almost 10 percent but look in
this year they say
over 5 5.3 growth and then next year
over 5
growth as well and when you compare the
uk with other countries around the world
we'll have a look at where we are so the
worst growth
of the g7 so industrialized seven
uh industrialized leading economies in
2020 uh more or less middle of the pack
in 2021
uh and then actually the strongest
growth of all of those g7 nations in
2022
but it's worth just looking at the level
of gdp growth because you get more of a
sense of kind of where we've come from
and where we're heading
uh from that so for instance this the
line here just shows you where we were
in 2019 so before the pandemic
down a lot in 2020 and then gradually
getting back up to that peak by 2022 so
regaining the peak
but when you compare the uk with other
countries around the world those g7
nations well look some of them
get back up to that peak a lot earlier
the us canada france in fact the uk
the second slowest to get back to where
it was before the pandemic here
but that's not just the only way of
looking at it you can also look at
scarring so
long-term damage from covert 19 a lot of
speculation as to whether there is going
to be that long-term damage
the way to do that is to compare where
for instance the imf thought that we
were going to be in 2024 so some way
after the pandemic
before it hit with what it now thinks
and anything below this line shows you
scarring
long-term damage and we can look at
different parts of the economy here
emerging economies uh they are talking
potentially about scoring
a 4.2 percent so permanent medium term
damage of 4.2 percent
on the level of gdp the world down by
2.8 so that's scarring for the global
economy
china down by 1.6 so a lot of people
thought china was going to do pretty
well
uh out of this period but actually uh
some scarring of 1.6 percent
to its level of growth and then you get
to a level of gdp and then advanced
economy is actually much less scarring
than china and other parts of the world
and look at this the us
no scarring in fact 0.5 percent stronger
than was expected before the pandemic
hit so actually it's been good news
for some parts of the economy in the
long run in terms of
the amount of scarring but much less
good news for other parts of the world